وانضم الينا من الخرطوم اسامه ابو بكر
المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني
اهلا بكم بدايه من خلال متابعتكم لتطورات
الاحداث على الارض الى اي مدى تقدرون ان
هناك التزاما بالهدنه التي تم تمديدتها
والله حتى
الان ماشيه
يمكن حسب ما بنشوف في الاعلام في اشتباكات
هنا وهناك
لكن نحن بنستفيد من اي هدنه حتى ولو كانت
محدوده وقصيره على اساس انه نحن نحاول
يعني نزيد من فعاليتنا ونستفيد من الهدنه
لكن طبعا نحن الهدنه عايزينها تكون اطول
من كده بشكل عام مش نحن في الهلال الاحمر
كل المؤسسات والمنظمات الانسانيه بتحاول
الهمه طويله اطول من كده وفيها ضمانات
اكثر الى اي مدى استفدتم حتى الان من
الهدن التي تم تطبيق
والله بتخلينا نتحرك شويه الهلال الاحمر
عندنا الاطقم بتاعتنا المتخصصه الاوليه
التحيه الاوليه والاخلاق
[موسيقى]
انه نوصل من بين المستشفيات وكذا نحن
بنساعد الكوادر الطبيه في 18 مستشفى
العاصمه ايضا الهدنه هي الهدنه في الخرطوم
انا ما عارف دلوقتي ناسنا في الولايات
لانه نحن شغالين في سته ولايات برضو فيها
احداث من الطرفين يعني
بنحاول ان احنا نستفيد الهدنه احيانا
الهدنه بتاعه الخرطوم بتختلف من الهدنه
بتاعه المناطق ماذا يختلف بين هدنه
الخرطوم وباقي الولايات
لانه هي الهدنه في اغلب الاحياء ما بتكون
ساريه على مستوى السودان يعني هي طبعا
لانه التركز الاحداث الخرطوم
بتكون فيه اعتبارات تعني لدى اطراف النزاع
في الولايات الثانيه يعني ممكن تكون في
جودان الجزئيه يعني ممكن يعمل مثلا في
مدينه من المدن معينه باتفاق الطرفين وكذا
على العموم هو في الولايات نحن شغالين
بالسعوديه اكثر شويه تعتمد طبعا على حسب
الولايه وعلى حسب اتصالاتنا
سؤال انه هل يتم التعرض لكم من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع او الجيش هل رصدتم تعرض لكم
من قبلهم ام انه يتم السماح لالياتكم
واطقمكم بالتحرك بحريه
ما حصل لحد هسه ما عندنا نحاسب انه
يتعارضوا لنا لسبب بسيط انه الطرفين الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني يعلمون بالضبط
الهلال الاحمر ما هو الهلال الاحمر
المؤسسه محايده مستقله عن السلطات
السياسيه ومستقله عن الحكومه وتعمل عمل
انساني بيستفيدوا منه حتى الطرفين يعني
احنا مثلا عندنا تجربه
اتعملت في مدينه
نيالا في ولايه جنوب كان في
ناس متوفيين زي السبعه قصص متوفيه تم
قتلهم في مناطق تابعه للطرف من الاطلاق
فيتصلنا بالجهتين بدعم السريع
الجيش السوداني
تجهيز باقي من المطوعين الهلال الاحمر
اخلوا هذه الجسس يعني هناك اتصالات بينكم
وبين الجيش وفي المقابل هل هناك اتصالات
خطوط اتصالات بينكم وبين قوات الدعم
السريع ايضا
طبعا نحن اتصالاتنا على الطرفين لانه احنا
نحنا جهاز جهه محايده بين الطرفين يعني
عما اننا نحمي الضحايا ونقدم المساعده
للضحايا ولو ما واثق فينا الطرفين في
حياتنا يعني ما حنقدر نشتغل بكل الثلاثه
عشان كذا في مدينه الجنينه عفوا في مدينه
نياله تم تطبيق هذه الحرفيا لشقط الطرفين
نحن عنصر محايد عندنا فريق بتاع اخلاء
الجسانين بيشتغل بالاسس العلميه وفقا
العالميه
اخذنا جسامين الطرف الى الطرف الاخر
قمتم هذه معلومه مهمه اذا قمتم من خلال
التنسيق بين الطرفين باخلاء جثامين وتبادل
جثامين المكونين وارسالهم لبعضهم البعض
خصوصا في المناطق التي تحدث فيها اشتباكات
هل هناك تقديرات لاعداد هذه الجثانين التي
تم نقلها
ان احنا
عندنا نتبع جسامين او البارح
اللي هي كانت تتبع
الاحاد احد الطرفين تم قتلهم في منطقه
سيطره الصدقه الاخر يعني
وبالتالي نحن عشان ننقل الجسامير نجيب
للطرف الثاني اللي هو
المتحارب مع الطرف ده نسقنا مع القوات
المسلحه ونستخدمها مع الدعم السريع
والاثنين قبلوا الوساطه بتاعتنا في اي مدى
تستفيدون من اتصالاتكم مع الجانبين ربما
لاخلاء باقي الجثث الموجوده في الخرطوم
كانت تقرر اشاره ونحن ندخل في الاسبوع
الثاني الى ان هناك الكثير من الجثث
موجوده في شوارع العاصمه هل ما زالت هذه
الجثث موجوده ام نجحتم في اخلائها
لا اول حاجه طبعا في الخرطوم الجثث عدد
كبير جدا واحد اتنين ارتفاع للرقعه
الجغرافيه بتاعت ولايه الخرطوم يعني نحن
لو عايزين نغطي ولايه الخرطوم كلها
بمحليات السبعه هي هي حاجه ضخمه جدا عدد
سكانها اصلا في الامتدادات الحضريه
والامتدادات الثانيه ولايه الخرطوم فيها
ما يقارب 10 مليون نسمه العشره مليون نسمه
للمواطنين طبعا
يشكل تقريبا اقل شويه من ربع سكان السودان
فالعمل في عمل صعب جدا يحتاج لضمانات
امنيه حتى الاطراف المتنازعه نطمن انه تصل
المعلومه لاصغر جندي في اي منطقه معينه
فنحن بنحاول نلقى مساحات بساعه حريه
بالتنسيق مع الطرفين واحيانا ما بكون في
تصديق بين الطرفين لكن احنا بنراهن على
فهم الطرفين لطبيعه عمل الاحمر وبنقوم
بهذه الاعمال يعني حصل اخل اء لبعض الجرحى
قريبين من احد المستشفيات ووصلناهم
للمستشفى وتم سلمناهم للطاقه الطبي هناك
وسلمناهم للطاقهم لسعد الطوافين السلبيه
التحديات التي تواجهونها في عملكم
بالاضافه الى اتساع رقعه العاصمه ايضا
وكما تحدثت انه هناك جثث كثيره ولا يمكن
ربما الوصول لها جميعا دون تنسيق
نعم نعم تقصد ابدا نشاطاتنا في مثل تحديات
التي تواجهكم في محاوله مساعده الناس
واخلاء الجرحى وايضا ربما بعض الجثث
التحديات التي تواجهنا بتتمثل في حاجتين
اول حاجه في عدم وجود ضمانات امنيه
على مستوى ولايه الطرطوم رغم انه الطرفين
بيعلن عن هدنه وقف اطلاق نار لكن نحن
بنحتاج بمانات امنيه لانه بالنسبه لنا
المتطوعين هذه الجثث او بقوه باعمالهم اهم
عنصر الهلال الاحمر خالص يعني عمنا
الموظفين المطوعين ناس بيضحوا حياتهم
بامكانياتهم الذاتيه شحيحه عشان يتحركوا
وبالتالي نحن ما بنرى امر برواحل
المتطوعين ما لم نتاكد تماما انه في
ضمانات علميه من كلا الطرفين لذلك المساله
تخضع لاتصالات احيانا بتكون ثنائي ما
بتكون اتصالات على المستوى المركزي ماذا
عن النقطه الثانيه
النقطه الثانيه اللي هي بالنسبه لاخلاء
الجرحى وبالنسبه لاخلاء الجسانين يعني
يعني اخلاء الجرحى متطوعين مثلا في ولايه
الخرطوم عندنا 254 متطوع
متخصصين في الاسعافات الاوليه لو تحدد لنا
ابرز الاماكن التي تحدث فيها الاشتباكات
والتي يمكن اعتبارها من قبلكم خطره
طبعا
نحن عندنا نقص عالي جدا جدا فهلال احمد
والنقص اصلا حتى في المستشفيات
والاجهزه
الطوارئ في المستشفيات سنقتحاد جدا جدا
بسبب بسيط جدا اي دعم خارجي
نحن عاده بنتلقى دعم هذه كبيره جدا اول
حاجه الدعم ده بقينا من اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر الذين الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر هي زي ما بيقولوا نحن زي الاشقاء
يعني كل واحد عنده دول اللجنه الدوليه
للطبيب الاحمر في حالات النزاعات المسلحه
هي الجهه الوحيده في العالم المفوضه
بالتدخل ومساعده ضحايا النزاع المسلح بكل
المقاييس
الطرفين او جرحى او مصابين يلا اللجنه
الدولية بتعتمد على الهلال الاحمر لانه
الهلال الاحمر هو عنده اكبر قاعده متطوعين
حسب الاحصائيات التي تعمل بتقبلين يمكن
سبع سنين عندنا في السودان 420 الف متطوع
جيد انا اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات التي
قدمتها لنا اسامه ابو بكر المسؤول
الاعلامي الهلال الاحمر السوداني كنت معنا
من الخرطوم لمتابعه المزيد اخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات